imagine that you're on a roll that you
love and there's a new opportunity on
the horizon it's one that you've been
working towards and that really gives
you a much bigger role in your company
at the same time you're also thinking of
starting a family and I'm wondering what
the best time to do that is what would
you do I was in this situation a couple
of years ago and I'd like to share my
story with you but before I get into
that I'd like to tell you about what
sort of what got me to Airbnb I had a
fairly straightforward path into tech I
was influenced by my brother
I played computer games got introduced
to programming I and computer science
I learned programming actually in
after-school classes in high school I
moved to the US for undergrad and that's
actually where I got enthralled by
computer science I realized that it was
a tool that I could just apply to so
many different fields biotech education
and and many others I found my niche in
a field called natural language
processing which is about how computers
can better understand how humans
interact how do we express ourselves
what do we say
and in senior year of high school now
most of my classmates were all applying
for jobs on Wall Street and it felt a
little bit crazy the path that I was
going down because it was so drastically
different from everyone else
I just felt that if I had the comfort of
a salary and a well-paying job that I
just might not want to go to grad school
I was fortunate that I immensely
respected both my advisor and my brother
that had done a PhD and I sort of you
know used that as support to kind of you
know go on that path I did a lot of
research in undergrad and grad school
and I thought that initially that I'd
might want to do a PhD but then
I really liked sort of the directly
affecting the end user and building
real-world applications and that's what
got me to Google I spent six years there
as an individual contributor I learned
how to build production systems how to
really build products for for the end
user and do machine learning at scale
and sort of you know looking back at
this I I would say it's it's important
to find that support system that's gonna
help you pursue your dreams you know
it's okay to do things that aren't like
your peers as long as you know you have
a lot of strong conviction and you know
where you're headed
I eventually landed it at Airbnb and I
fundamentally believe that you know
planning planning a trip planning a
travel experience was just difficult and
we had the power to create really
meaningful experiences I also believe
that accommodations finding a place to
stay was just one part of that entire
travel journey in 2014 I started what we
call the discovery team and the goal
here was to help guests find an imp
occurred esta nation so this was people
that were higher up in the intent funnel
and you know I think this product ended
up being a bit ahead of its time and at
the end of the year we sort of decided
to focus on more core search efforts but
the time for this actually came again in
2016 we as a company we're going to
launch a new vertical called experiences
and we were gonna put out this vision
for how we want to effect sort of all of
travel it was a very exciting time for
the company and I had something exciting
going on in my personal life I was
pregnant with our first baby and you
know I sort of at that point or if I
actually think just more generally I
felt that I always wanted to find a job
that I was super excited and passionate
about and also balance that with with
sort of balance work in personal life
and I felt that enough people weren't
talking about this you know as women and
I think maybe everyone sort of you want
time things pretty perfectly you know
how does it work with this job that
you're going after or this promotion
that you want and I remember I was
having conversations with my husband
where I said you know maybe we should
just wait two months because then this
it'll line up perfectly with this
project and you know looking back it's
actually so silly because you know
there's there's just so many unknowns
with having a baby and you also just you
know or when you think of the grand
scheme of things two months here or
there is nothing or you know even just
six months it just it really doesn't
matter and you know I sort of kind of
got past that and and I was gonna be out
on leave starting July of last year and
the launch was in in November and at
that point I I did feel pretty bummed
because I said okay what does this mean
for my career it was this great
opportunity that I wasn't gonna be a
part of and you know it's it's a
deadline you you're gonna go you can't
sort of extend it or anything and so I
went out on leave and you know when I
came back I sort of it was quite an
experience actually getting just getting
used to sort of the new normal I
remember that first week I had a goal of
coming in at 9:00 a.m. and I I think I
just it literally was 10 a.m. every
single day that I got in and we had this
perk at work where we could take off a
day for each week for eight weeks and I
didn't end up using that I instead just
gave myself a lot more flexibility and I
also told myself that okay November and
December is gonna be just an easier sort
of time back into work and I think this
actually also helped me with just what
ended up being a role change for me so
my manager ended up leading this new
effort the trips team and that meant
that there was a roll open and so I took
on sort of leading the umbrella team and
so I went from managing 40 engineers 200
with that change and then you know a few
months later in June of this year we
again we organized ourselves into
businesses and we brought together a
whole bunch of teams
and created a new one called Holmes and
I lead engineering for that and when and
and you know I I grew my team from sort
of hundred to two hundred fifty and you
know it was one of those things that if
I'd been optimizing so carefully for
each step you know I might not have even
gotten this opportunity and sort of you
know the lesson that I learned in all of
this is that you sort of you don't by
not by closing some door and your
personal or in your professional life it
might sort of you might not know what
the impact of that is on your personal
life and vice versa and so really just
think of what you want to optimize for
optimize for what's important to you
because the worst thing is that you have
resentment later on
[Applause]
and the final part of my talk is going
to be on just that relationship with
your manager so a lot of people talk
about how important it is to have a
mentor or a sponsor and I agree with
that but I also want to say that
cultivating that relationship with your
manager is incredibly important if you
think of how you're gonna get
opportunities at work your manager has
to advocate for you right they are the
ones that they might not have the
opportunity available but they are the
ones that are gonna tell your story and
think about you when the right
opportunity in the organization comes
about so I would really think of sort of
what you the relationship you have with
your manager and try to think of whether
they understand what success means for
you and can they connect the dots and
line up your career goals with other
opportunities another thing I want to
call out is that disagreement is okay
you know it's just it manages your
relationship with your manager is just
another relationship you have just as
one with your friends you have to
nurture it if there's tension you have
to get through it and really understand
what's at the root of it you know with I
had something with my manager where we
had to figure out how we were going to
work together and it was a new team that
I took on from him and we tried to get
to the root of really what we what was
important to us what was important for
the team and when we worked backwards
from there everything was much easier um
so I would say really invest in that
relationship with your manager my
manager played a big part in the role
that I have today because he was the one
that advocated for me to his manager who
ran all of engineering and you know I'm
at this position now at Airbnb which is
which is exciting
so at the beginning of this talk I asked
you what you would do in my situation
and it's it's a trick question really
because there's no wrong answer and
that's what I'd like to leave you with
today when it comes to your life you
should do what feels right to you and be
flexible in times of change because you
never know what door is gonna open up
for you in your professional life thank
you